incoming time flex yes I am of God
the god of speed
Hyper one happy crisis on Infinite
Earths this is gonna be my flash season
6 episode 1 video because we just found
out that God speed is totally coming
back right away surprise surprise they
completely changed the timeline so it
sounds like they're gonna completely
redo the god speed character so we'll
break everything down we'll do it a new
round of that IMAX ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite flash
villain on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this the reason why
we know about God's be coming back is
because they're filming episode 1 for
most of the shows even Stephen Amell
tweeted this picture of arrows first
episode getting ready to film one last
time was his caption because this is the
last season of arrow on the side of the
flash they're filming a battle outside
and it's the flash fighting Godspeed it
doesn't look like the same actor either
he looks a little bit different he's
growing a bigger beard there it looks
like the flash rips his mask off at some
point during the fight so that he can
see who he's fighting so I'm guessing
it's probably still August heart but
because there's been so many timeline
changes as of the end of season 5 is
basically a completely different
character during this fight they also
debut the brand new killer frost costume
danielle Panabaker posted this to her
Facebook account I think because so many
paparazzi were taking pictures of this
big bite but like okay we'll post a nice
shiny version of this we're not trying
to hide it so just expect it to show up
during the comic-con trailer next week
that's right Comic Con trailers for all
this stuff dropping next week but the
larger question is is what's going on
with Godspeed during flash season 6
because I never expected him to be the
main villain based on the way they
treated him during season 5 and he's
from Nora's time in 20 49 so how would
he be back in present-day now it all
probably has something to do with crisis
on Infinite Earths so there's only a
couple of ways that he can actually be
here now but a lot of you have been
asking who the villain for flash season
6 is going to be and there's a lot of
really good guesses I've seen but you
have to think about this season
differently for all the shows because of
crisis on Infinite Earths so what
they're doing is is the first half of
the season on all the shows is gonna be
way more comic book II that you ever
seen before particularly on arrow in the
flash but you have everything that's
building towards crisis in the first
half of the season then you have a 5
episode crossover that's gonna take
place broken up into two different parts
there'll be three episode
in December and then two episodes of the
crossover won't happen till all the
shows come back in January after the
hiatus arrows only got 10 episodes of
this season all the other shows have the
regular amount so they'll continue on
the back half they'll go on to whatever
their regular plots are in the wake of
crisis on Infinite Earths however that
wraps up it'll change the universe going
forward worlds will live worlds will die
as the poster says worlds will live
worlds will die and the universe so
whatever is happening on the flash this
season there'll be some stuff that's
affected by crisis but they're already
doing their own plot so whoever the
villain is for the flash season 6 the
main villain it'll have something to do
with crisis but it won't be completely
tied to that so reverse-flash is not
gonna be the main villain this season
even though he's a big part of what's
going on they revealed the title of the
second episode of season 6 episode 2 is
called a flash of the lightning and
that's the title of the story where
Barry sacrificed himself during the
original comic book crisis on Infinite
Earths
and I think it's pretty safe to say that
Barry's not gonna die or sacrifice
himself completely in the second episode
of the season so episode 2 is probably
just the episode where they address the
ramifications of what's happening with
the accelerated timeline for crisis on
Infinite Earths crossover this year but
you'll remember that the last we saw of
godspeed was he was in 2049 in that
special noir episode where they were
explaining how she realized she got
powers and they basically did a
highlight reel of the first three
seasons of the flash with the villains
from the first three seasons so that the
writers could say that all the same
stuff that happened to Barry the first
couple of seasons also happened to Nora
but in slightly different ways in
pursuit of that they changed the
godspeed character from the comics to
make him more like zoom turned him into
a velocity 9 speedster he was still
August Hart but he was a former mercury
lab scientist from Nora's future who was
fired when he was caught experimenting
on humans trying to recreate the
velocity-9 formula in the comics after
the Speed Force storm at the beginning
of flash rebirth a bunch of people got
speed comic-book god speed went around
stealing all their speed and killing
them on the TV show August Hart wound up
killing all of his test subjects
so they were doing a version of comic
book Godspeed just changing it to fit
with this future timeline but here's the
thing about that whole god speed episode
the character in that future timeline is
that Nora was completely erased from the
timeline at the end of season 5 because
her entire timeline was changed as part
of reverse Flash's secret double-cross
to free himself from prison in 20 49 so
it wasn't just Nora that completely
changed everything that happened
originally in that future so August
heart becoming godspeed all that stuff
was wiped from the timeline basically
giving the flash writers a do-over
for everything with the Nora character
with the godspeed character anything
that happened the future the Red Death
character that they named dropped during
that future episode so where did this
new godspeed come from there's only a
couple ways he could be here in
present-day fighting the flash I just
broke this down top-5 style and most of
it has to do with crisis on Infinite
Earths and the alterations to the
timeline number 5 it could still be the
original god speed and he somehow found
a way to make more velocity 9 while he
was stuck in prison in 20 49 he escaped
and then got into the timestream to
protect himself from the changes to the
timeline at the end of the season then
he could have come back in time to
change the past trying to create a new
future timeline that would benefit him
more speedsters coming back to the Past
to alter the timeline to benefit them is
straight out of the reverse flashes
playbook for the timeline changes could
have created a new version of August
heart Godspeed who's still from the
future in 20 49 whose backstory just
happens to be different and he's come
back in time to steal something changed
something about the timeline to benefit
himself in the future so same basic idea
just very different origin story for who
this version of August heart Godspeed is
three reverse-flash who escaped at the
end of last season and teased crisis on
Infinite Earths
that scene was so great because it
sounds like he knows exactly what's
coming up reverse-flash could be behind
this new version of Godspeed
manipulating him the same way he
manipulated Nora to alter the timeline
sending him back in time to harass team
flash and set a larger crisis plot in
motion because what they do a lot of
times with the first episode of each new
season is use it as a sort of bridge
between the stuff they were doing
last season in the new different stuff
they're gonna be doing in the new season
the whole idea last season is that
reverse-flash was manipulating the
timeline in the past to benefit him in
the future
so God speed versus the flash in Episode
one could be a bit of a hold over wink
at that before they get into the actual
plot of the season reverse-flash prides
himself on having the most nuanced
understanding of how the timeline works
there was even that crazy quote I am the
only one who understands what's going on
so he's probably one of the few people
that understands why everything's
happening at 2019 now instead of 2020
for laughing the whole way they're like
oh just you wait flash just you wait
till you see what happens to you now
because of all the stuff that I've done
to the changes to the timeline could
have just vastly sped up when God speed
became god speed so that he's more of a
present-day recurring villain instead of
being a villain for Nora and then number
one probably most likely scenario is
that he's just the tip of the flash
villain iceberg in season six and
because of crisis on Infinite Earths
this year the writers are going to make
the flash run the gauntlet of all the
most comic book II villains they can
possibly do and they'll use that
opportunity to fix a lot of the issues
quote-unquote that the characters had
when they were last used so wasn't
really hot about some of the stuff they
did with the godspeed character during
season five where they changed his
backstory kind of made him a once-off
villain for Nora so it sounds like this
is an opportunity for them to fix that
in the first episode and then pave the
way for the actual main villain of the
season to come a few episodes later
because every season on the flash
you never really meet the biggest
villain in the very first episode they
might tease him a little bit in a
post-credits scene but the main villain
usually doesn't become a really big
actual part of the plot until a little
bit later the first half of the season
the things that they're doing
differently this year though is because
of crisis on Infinite Earths is that
they're breaking the seasons up into a
couple different villains so don't be
surprised if there's a main villain for
the first half of the season on our way
into crisis then after crisis completely
changes the foundation of the DC TV
universe they'll do something a little
bit different so that we're not stuck
with another cicada situation like last
year with them just dragging that whole
plot out over 22 episodes just was not a
huge fan of the secatur character in the
way that they double down on
in the second half of the season based
on what I think they're doing with
godspeed this season it's also possible
that they do the Red Death character
because if Red Death was going to be a
speedster I wasn't expecting them to be
the main villain of flash season 6 the
only way that they make Red Death the
main villain is if it's a non speedster
character and they changed the character
even more from the comics which they
already have to do because they can't do
Batman and I don't expect it to be a
Batman comic book Red Death twist where
you have like a Batman character
combined with a flash character from an
alternate universe Red Death in the
comics is a dark universe version of
Bruce Wayne that combined himself with a
Barry Allen from his earth to create a
new character that he's dominating in a
very firestorm situation where you have
a Barry Allen trapped his consciousness
trapped in the body with the Red Death
but the evil version of Bruce Wayne is
sort of in control of the body doing all
these terrible things with those powers
there is a version of Batman that's
gonna be on Titan season - played by
Jorah Mormont's from Game of Thrones but
that's the only Batman you're gonna see
on any kind of DC comic book TV show in
the Titans stuff isn't a different
universe than what's happening with DC
TV in all the crisis stuff
I love the new killer frost costume it
looks way more comic-book II inspired by
the rebirth version of the killer frost
costume her shoulders are exposed the
snowflake symbol is way more prominent
on her chest it's a little more
form-fitting and less of a big heavy
winter coat like we saw during season 3
like I said they're dropping Comic Con
trailers for all this stuff next week
but here's the problem though all that
DC TV stuff like the flash panel is
happening right in the middle of
Marvel's phase 4 panel where they're
showing off a whole bunch of footage
from all their phase 4 movies so what'll
probably happen is is I'll do my Marvel
video that night and then I'll do my
flash trailer video and DC TV stuff the
next morning on Sunday as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see all the videos when I post
them if you have any big questions about
what's going on in the DC Universe just
leave all your questions in the comments
and I'll add it to the list of videos
that I'm making congratulations
Christian Smith you're the giveaway
winner from my last big DC video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details click here for
that new Superman Shazam deleted
and click here for all of my spider-man
far from home Easter eggs and post
credits scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight